port of Belfast accounts for 64% of
Northern Ireland's freight traffic half
a million trucks a year passed through
here fetching and carrying products
between the UK mainland in the island of
Ireland but with Ireland in the EU and
the UK now out new checks extra
paperwork and added costs are inevitable
we've grave concerns with grave concerns
about our business models with grave
concerns about choice of also grave
concerns about affordability for
Northern Ireland households quite simply
there can't afford cost rises from
fraction and what this plan has at the
moment is lots of fraction the amount
and intrusiveness of the new customs
declarations will form part of the
transition negotiations we were
obviously want that there are mitigation
for this because to come across the
Irish Sea the volume of trade on that
it'd be it'd be a hugely time-consuming
and expensive formality for drivers and
businesses tough to completely we hope
maybe there's common sense on both sides
were we alleviate the need for that
O'Neill's is a multi-million dollar
sportswear company with factories in the
north and the south and a manufacturing
process built on frictionless movement
between them from the ROI yot to the
finished product here these shirts from
O'Neill's go through a complex series of
stages about eight of them in all
cutting printing embroidery sewing and
coloring and crossing from the factory
here in Strabane down to a sister
Factory in Dublin and then back again
through the process now a hard border
and no deal brexit would be a nightmare
for this company but the MD here is
reasonably optimistic I do think there's
a good opportunity know here for the
economy of Northern Ireland he goes to
the end of the day you'll find direct
investors we look at Northern and a
country that has a smaller foot in both
counts you know free trade with you know
the 27 member states of the European
Union and I'll say access to the UK as
well not everyone agrees on the Irish
side of the border up in County Donegal
the bulk fertilisers animal feeds and
equipment at this farmers cooperative
mainly come from ports in Northern
Ireland and the frictionless way the
farmers currently send their livestock
and produce to market looks set to end
some of the arguments that have been
made is that it will be
like a digital type order you cross it's
seamless you hardly know you cross but
all of that adds a lot of cost I was
long enough doing haulage to know what
it was like to have to do customs papers
to get through from here to Dublin we
had it we have four border crossings to
do down and up and it was delays and
paperwork and we don't want to go back
to that where it was a nightmare in the
next 11 months of trade negotiations a
specialized committee will represent
Northern Ireland's specific interests
but the challenge is complex and the
time is short